voici nicolas rey louis la mer
c'est bien là très bien on n'a pas que
tu es venu on avait eu louis l'anr par
raccroc aujourd'hui il vient vraiment
pour la sortie de son livre qui
s'appelle un pur roman c'est publié
évidemment au diable vauvert comme tout
ce que vous faites tous les deux vous
êtes au diable vauvert
voilà le pitch louis basset l'histoire
de virgile qui à 26 ans qui comme
beaucoup de gens rêvent de faire de la
télé et donc il s'imagine bien que le
dernière univers rock n roll dans lequel
il va pouvoir s'amuser c'est justement
la télé il pense qu'il va pouvoir sortir
avec des filles plus belle que
qu'ailleurs qui va pouvoir faire des
choses extraordinaires comme peut-être
partir en week-end avec avec séverine
ferrer favon des choses comme ça c'est
magique dans ce livre il est là il veut
devenir une star il n'est pas le seul on
va tous devenir les stars maintenant
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui suis très
content d'être enfin invité
officiellement j'ai pu venir sans s'en
taper le vigile à l'entrée
il y avait même une demie loges pour moi
voilà un verre de champagne donc c'est
magique ça va j'ai lié à un extrait d'un
pur romance bien énervé boubam comme
tous les enfants riches
je suis beau les papas riche épouse de
belle maman je suis l'ultime
aboutissement de cette sélection par
l'argent comme tous les beaux enfants je
serai bientôt une star j'ai du temps
pour ça je n'ai pas besoin de dépenser
mon énergie à gagner ma vie ma vie est
déjà gagné j'ai une [ __ ] de longueur
d'avancé sur vous pendant que vous serez
bloqué dans la queue du casting de la
star academy 6 j'aurais déjà écrit le
scénario de star ac 7
la vie est injuste je suis la preuve
vivante que le pays n'est pas une
république que les hommes ne naissent
pas égaux en droits et le demeure encore
moins je ne suis pas votre égal mais si
vous pouviez croire en cette égalité
révolutionnaire ça m'arrangerait bien
pensé que tout le monde peut être star
suivent les conseils démocratiques des
profs qui nous demande de rester
vous-même surtout restez vous mêmes ne
changez rien vous êtes parfait
c'est là tu te démerdes louis en temps
c'est toi qui l'a écrit c'est vrai pour
cinq ans louis en fait moi je n'ai rien
à voir avec ce héros en fait moi j'ai un
garçon très tendres j'ai eu une histoire
d'amour un petit peu compliqué avec une
fille qui s'appelle céline qui me
regardera pas ce soir et c'est une fille
pas mal si je peux faire rêver un petit
peu les gens qu'est ce que je peux dire
elle a 25 ans bon ça déjà ça fait rêver
je pense ensuite elle a un tatouage de
salamandre sur la hanche droite
elle a une peau couleurs sucrées mais
vraiment sucre de canne
un petit peu un petit peu comme toi
elodie et et c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que pour moi c'est difficile et l'espace
car de fermer ta gueule c'est pas mal
écrit c'est très bien c'est bien écrit
c'est c'est bien les crimes et c'est
énervant
et oui mais comme toutes les choses un
peu m ça qu'ils sont comme ça à ce point
réussie si les monty python avaient fait
l'amour avec des proches a redonné louis
lannes hervé mons a pas été le cas
et en plus il ya un plaisir de lecture
il médias évident c'est la phrase de
tolstoï on oublie qu'on lit vraiment et
moi j'ai eu je n'ai même fini alors que
ton premier j'avais pas son premier
livre j'avais moins fini et celui 6 les
noms je n'ai jamais fini je les trouvais
formidable fait pas le voyage au bout de
la nuit non plus un an et mais pour
l'été c'est excellent comme on arrive
quasiment anti bubba waton je suis pas
le bad boy de la littérature on peut pas
dire ça non c'est en même temps il est
très sauvages parfois je m'en suis rendu
compte alors de toucher un livre vous
dites vous avez changé complètement de
si vous allez décrire une enfance
asthmatiques j'avais pas de papa et où
vous allez faire pleurer un peu
peut-être que finalement peut-être que
ça pourrait mieux fonctionner dans notre
prochain livre je crois qu'on va
peut-être écrire un nicolas qui sont en
cours je t'en parle maintenant là parce
qu'on a envie honorer le dit mais j'y
pense si vous voulez faire un livre à
quatre mains un livre à quatre mains
on regardait la ferme tous les soirs
avec louis lui s'y connaît et nous on
avait une c'est vrai une vision des miss
france
un peu comme ça impeccable au ph neutre
et tout et vous il y avait quelque chose
d'un peu d'un peu salée joli à regarder
comme si vous sentiez la sueur et ça
c'était le droit et non en 2004
maintenant c'est vrai c'est vrai louis
l'anr vis-à-vis peu sur les traces de
frédéric beigbeder de nicholas ray enfin
cette cette nouvelle littérature qu'on
peut appeler un peu la littérature tête
à claques donc un ca des jeunes gens
riches et beaux qui le proclame
et ça énerve les autres ouais mais c'est
parce que moi j'avais une mère prof de
français approuvent prof de philo un
grand père prof de patois lorrain donc
j'essaie de me projeter la demande un
certain docteur de sortir c'est entre
beigbeder nicholas ray vous préférez qui
souvent l'associent nicolas rey et
beigbeder et c'est étrange parce que je
trouve que c'est pas du tout la même
littérature enfin on va voir une
interview nicolas rey contre beigbeder
et c'est vous qui répondait